we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p today i have
a voicemail from a psychiatric nurse who
claims claims to know what it is that
happened to donald trump relating to
that unexpected hospital visit a couple
of weeks ago let's take a listen to her
perspective hi david this is Katherine
retired psychiatric nurse
I've told you a few times I think
probably what happened to trumpet when I
went to the hospital is that he fell
because it is later through alley in
Florida he has a new pair of piece and
it's covering what looks like his right
cheek a little bit too much there's like
the hair is too thick and the cheek
looks swollen I mean he always looks
swollen but if I don't I'm looking for
my phone I don't have it on the big
screen so maybe it's not so but that's
just my impression yeah this is actually
really interesting because number one
nobody even speculated about a fall but
interestingly Donald Trump recently
getting off of the lower stairs off of
Air Force One several times and we said
well that could be if there's concern
about him falling sometimes accompanied
side by side by someone deplaning with
him when he comes off the big stairs
recently the idea being there's someone
there to sort of keep him up against the
side of the stairs again to prevent
falling I went back and looked at the
rally that is mentioned here and it is
true that Donald Trump I mean listen I
guess he denies wearing a toupee if you
believe that he wears one there was a
puff of hair on his left cheek I think
she says the right it is the right side
if you're watching the rally with Trump
facing you but it's Trump's left there
is a puff of hair there again it could
just be windblown I don't really know
and and again it does sort of seem like
the left cheek area is kind of swollen
so this is the first I've heard of it
found it interesting that if you were
noticed this I can tell you only to go
back and look at the floor to rally
footage yourself and make of it what you
will we have such a great bonus show for
you today I am going to tell you some
Thanksgiving stories number one I will
also tell you about a sort of social
experiment that I ran with the Black
Friday membership special I'm not gonna
say anymore I think you will find this
really really interesting and I hope
that you will sign up either at join
pakman.com or by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show I
think you will find today's social
experiment that I reveal on the bonus
show very very interesting and
compelling I'll speak to you then or
otherwise tomorrow and yes we will be
live-streaming Wednesday's impeachment
inquiry hearings on at least YouTube if
not YouTube and twitch more in that on
tomorrow's program